هذا ما قلته وهو دليل على ضروره ان تتعامل
الدول مع هذا الميدان من مقاربه حيويه
وكيف يمكنها ضمان الانترنت لمواطنينها في
كل الظروف والاوقات العصيبه مثل الحرب
الروسيه
بينطبق هذا على على اوروبا بينطبق على
الهند بقيه الدول بقيه الدول العالم الصين
مثلا
الاتحاد الاوروبي على معرفه دقيقه بهذه
الملفات ويعمل على تغيير مناهجه بشانها
وحكوماتها تنخرط في انشاء الكابلات لقد
باتت تمنح تمويلات بملايين الدولارات
لمقاولين من مواطنيها وتبني شركات لضميان
ان يكون لكل دوله اوروبيه جزء في خطوط
الكابلات بما يضمن الانترنت وسيادتها على
الخطوه
[موسيقى]
لا اعرف ما اذا كان لي فريق تمتلكم
نيه تتعلق بهم كونغ اعرف ان هذا الفريق
شكله دونالد ترامب في خدم جدالهم عاصين
وخاصه بشان تكنولوجيا المعلومات
والتطبيقات والذكاء وكل شؤون الرقميه لكن
يمكنني ان اقول لك بكل ثقه ان الضرر الذي
لحق عده شركات امريكيه جاءها من شركات
الاتصال الامريكيه اكثر لا من نظيراتها
الصينيه وانها هي التي كانت عرضه
لانقطاعات اكثر من الشركات الاسيويه
[موسيقى]